you guys gonna do glycerin live okay but
first time I heard that song I thought
it was misery right I didn't even know
it was glycerine glycerine I don't I
think that's the stuff that blows up
right it's glycerine right so life are
you trying to say that life is as
dangerous as glycerine I was trying to
say that the person I was writing a song
about was as dangerous as serene
nitroglycerin Wow
see I got that what this person yeah who
was it it was a girlfriend of mine
called Susie Susie yeah this is a really
great song
[Music]
it must be your skin I must be feeling
real is now I can feel the I didn't mind
and not my kind not my time wondering
why think I'm white and everything's
great now you are here no you
I don't want this remember I never
forget where your
don't let the days go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm never alone I'm a long time are you
I don't want do you I live in a whale
everyone steals but when we arise it's
like Strawberry Fields treated you bad
you bruised my face to love you more
you've got beautiful taste don't let the
knees go
[Music]
could've been easy
you I couldn't change
it should have been easy I like three
often film you
[Music]
don't let the taste go
[Applause]
don't let the days go
[Music]
I
[Music]
this ring buckless ring
[Music]
this ring
[Applause]
Batman one Yin
but when one young as she falls around
I needed more warning us less I could
not kiss just Rick grass might just be
your simple plain that's just fine
that's just one of my name's don't let
the days go by
[Applause]
[Music]
Cunanan easy are you
this ring
disarray
[Music]
yeah